and the Oscar goes to
Grant major for Lord of the Rings
Return of the King the set declaration
well on behalf of all of us in the art
Department of The Lord of the Rings it's
uh it's such a great moment to be here
and uh thank you very much to the
academy it's been a long journey for us
all and it's just such an incredible
high note to finish it finished it on
it's been an amazing ride I'd like to
thank Uline Bob Shea and Michael line
Michael Lynn Michael desky and of course
the lake color fry
and I'd like to thank the real wizard
who led us all through this amazing
journey Peter Jackson thank you very
very much for delivering these to us
and um
and That's all folks yeah